- C'est un grand plaisir
d'être ici aujourd'hui
pour vous parler d'Air Canada.
- Le discours a duré 26 minutes.
Le pdg d'Air Canada a parlé
en français une
de secondes. Tout le reste
s'est passé en anglais.
Lors de son allocution,
Michael Rousseau a dit bien
comprendre la langue de Molière,
mais a souligné avoir
de la difficulté à la parler.
Sauf qu'en point de presse,
il est incapable de comprendre
les questions qui lui
sont adressées en français
et demande qu'on les pose
en anglais.
L'homme, qui habite la région de
Montréal depuis 14 ans, affirme
qu'il n'a aucun problème à vivrr
dans l'autre langue
officielle du pays.
Et il ne s'engage pas
à l'apprendre, du moins
pas pour l'instant.
Il est trop occupé, dit-il,
à faire redécoller Air Canada,
alors que le transporteur
se remet de la pandémie.
La Chambre de commerce
du Montréal métropolitain,
qui a invité Michael Rousseau
à prononcer un discours,est déçe
des événements.
MICHEL LEBLANC, prés. Chambre de
commerce du Mtl métropolitain
- Aujourd'hui, j'ai été surprisn
comprenait très peu de français
et que le président d'Air Canada
n'a pas déclaré publiquement
que son intention, c'était
d'apprendre le français.
- Air Canada est assujettie à la
Loi sur les langues officielles
et doit donc servir ses clients
en anglais ou en français
selon rence.rence.rence.rence.r.
La nomination d'un dirigeant
unilingue envoie un mauvais
message, selon le commissaire
aux langues officielles.
RAYMOND THÉBERGE, commissaire
aux langues officielles, Canada
- Mon souhait, ça serait
qu'à l'avenir, M. Rous
comme tout pdg d'une entreprise
assujettie à la Loi sur
les langues officielles,
n mesure de communiquer
dans les deux langues
officielles.
- Même son de cloche de la
ministre responsable des langues
officielles sur Tw
"Les dirigeants d'Air Canada
doivent montrer l'exemple",
dit-elle.
Le ministre québécois
Simon Jolin-Barrette affirme,
pour sa part, que "le grand
patron d'Air Canada exprime
le mépris pour notre langue
et notre culture, des propos
qui sont indignetions
qu'il occupe", selon lui.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.